[Música]
el secretario general de la otan jens
stoltenberg pidió a los países de la
alianza atlántica que entreguen a
Ucrania nuevos sistemas de defensa aérea
tras la escalada de la ofensiva rusa
precisamente hoy Rusia volvió a
bombardear las ciudades saporiya
conectaremos con Bruselas
el sindicato cgt aseguró que llevará
ante los tribunales la medida del
gobierno francés que obliga a los
trabajadores en paro a volver al trabajo
la huelga de los empleados de la
refinerías ha generado un gran deseo
abastecimiento de combustible
hoy el 12 de octubre se conmemora en
gran parte de América y en España la
llegada de Cristóbal Colón al continente
americano una llegada que dio pie a la
colonización española del continente por
lo que celebrar la fecha es motivo de
malestar entre gran parte de la
población que recuerda el genocidio de
los pueblos indígenas analizamos en esta
emisión
Buenos días Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Fran 34 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición con información a
relacionada con la guerra en Ucrania en
Bruselas se celebra la primera reunión
de la otan desde la anexión a Rusia de
los territorios de lugans doness gerson
y saporiya en el encuentro el secretario
general de la organización jeans
stoltenberg agradeció a los miembros de
la alianza atlántica el envío de nuevos
sistemas de defensa antiaéreos a kiev
ante la escalada de la ofensiva rusa
recordemos que tras la explosión del
sábado en el puente de crimea de la que
Rusia acusa Ucrania el lunes las fuerzas
de Moscú lanzaron un ataque masivo con
81 misiles sobre todo el territorio
ucraniano incluida kiev la capital como
resultado al menos 20 personas murieron
y decenas de civiles resultaron heridos
escuchemos ahora las palabras del
secretario general de la otan y del
Secretario de Defensa de Estados Unidos
este tipo de contacto dirigido por
Estados Unidos para Ucrania y también
una cena con los ministros de la otan
más tarde hoy donde discutiremos
abordaremos Cómo aumentar el apoyo a
Ucrania y la principal prioridad será
más defensa aérea para
ucranias For what
el mundo entero acaba de ver una vez más
la malicia y la crueldad de la guerra
elegida por el presidente ruso Vladimir
Putin arraigada en la agresión y librada
con profundo desprecio por las reglas de
la guerra
el último bombardeo de Rusia contra las
ciudades de Ucrania ha vuelto a matar y
herir a inocentes civiles y poner
objetivos sin fines militares en el
punto de mira pero los últimos ataques
de Rusia Solo han profundizado la
determinación del pueblo ucraniano y han
Unido aún más a los países de buena
voluntad en todas las regiones del mundo
a continuación les traemos los detalles
de los sistemas de defensa que solicita
Ucrania a la otan se trata de equipos
parecidos al sistema antimisiles cúpula
de hierro de Israel
[Música]
armas terroríficas que descienden del
cielo a velocidades Aparentemente
imposibles estos drones suicidas y
misiles de cruceros son disparados en
masa desde barcos y aviones rusos
Moscú ha estado enviando una lluvia de
destrucción sobre Ucrania durante dos
días lo que ha llevado al presidente
bolodimir selenski a pedir ayuda urgente
a los países del g7
les pido que refuercen Nuestro esfuerzo
conjunto para ayudar financieramente a
crear un escudo aéreo para Ucrania
Ucrania pretende instalar la llamada
cúpula de hierro similar a los sistemas
de defensa antimisiles que existen en
Israel o alrededor de Washington DC la
capital estadounidense está protegida
por el Sistema Nacional avanzado de
misiles tierra aire o nasams para
Ucrania esta tecnología podría ser un
escudo crucial en 10 segundos el sistema
puede detectar misiles enemigos y
destruirlos en pleno vuelo creando en
efecto una burbuja de protección
el sistema nasams tiene una capacidad de
interceptación de hasta 150 kilómetros
el uso principal de ese sistema Sería
para la defensa de kiev y la defensa de
las principales ciudades en concreto
actualmente no podemos hacer una burbuja
100% impenetrable incluso con muchos
sistemas combinados de múltiples capas
en un solo lugar según el Ministerio de
defensa de Ucrania la mitad de los 84
misiles de crucero rusos fueron
interceptados el lunes como aquí
nos dé un soldado ucraniano utilizó un
misil disparado desde el hombro con gran
efecto para su defensa antiaérea kiev
despliega actualmente pequeños
lanzadores de misiles portátiles y
sistemas s-300 desarrollados por la
antigua Unión soviética El martes llegó
desde Alemania el primer sistema de
defensa antiaérea Iris más sofisticado
mientras Estados Unidos ha aprobado el
envío de al menos 8 baterías de sus
afamados nasams a Ucrania
y continuamos con noticias relacionadas
con la guerra en Ucrania porque el apoyo
de Bruselas a kiev ha asumido al bloque
comunitario en una crisis energética por
los recortes en el suministro Ruso y el
consiguiente encarecimiento de los
precios de las fuentes alternativas por
lo que reunidos hoy en Praga los
ministros de energía de la Unión Europea
avanzaron en las discusiones sobre cómo
reformar el mercado eléctrico para
limitar la escalada sin precedentes de
las facturas energéticas nuestra
corresponsal en la capital europea
Esther Herrera nos amplía sobre el
encuentro
la reunión de ministros de energía que
se ha producido en Praga ya ha terminado
Y aunque no se esperaban resultados
concretos Sobre qué es lo que se puede
hacer para bajar los precios de la
energía Así que ha ayudado a acercarse a
este punto qué es lo que se puede hacer
para poder abaratar los precios de la
electricidad la gran mayoría de países
está a favor de que se deben abaratar
estos precios pero aún no se han puesto
de acuerdo en cómo se puede hacer aún
así la gran mayoría sí que accede por
ejemplo hacer una compra conjunta de gas
entre todos los países Y así pueda
costar mucho menos el gas que se importa
en este sentido la comisión europea va a
anunciar nuevas medidas ya la semana que
viene Como por ejemplo esta compra
conjunta de gas pero también una de las
mayores discusiones donde hay menos
consenso es en la de poner un límite en
el precio del gas los líderes tendrán
que abordarlo la semana que viene en una
reunión extraordinaria aquí en Bruselas
vamos ahora a Francia porque el
Sindicato de trabajadores cgt afirmó que
impugnará ante los tribunales la
decisión del gobierno de obligar a
trabajadores en huelga a volver a sus
puestos de trabajo en el depósito de la
petrolera Epson Mobile en normandía tras
semanas de escasez causada por los paros
en refinerías tanto de Epson como de
total donde continúan las huelgas el
sindicato alega que el gobierno vulnera
así el derecho a la huelga Marta Moya
con los detalles
el gobierno francés ha cumplido sus
amenazas los empleados en huelga de este
depósito de exxon Mobile tendrán que
volver al trabajo o enfrentarse a
sanciones penales los enfurece porque se
está violando nuestro derecho a la
huelga desde el principio a nuestro
movimiento ha sido Pacífico obviamente
nosotros cgt En cuanto tengamos estas
demandas presentaremos denuncias a
través de nuestros abogados por el
momento la obligación a trabajar no se
refiere a las actividades de la
refinerías y por tanto a la producción
de combustible
pero el objetivo es permitir el
transporte de la gasolina que ya está
almacenada allí 6 de las siete
refinerías seguían cerradas el miércoles
algunas desde hace más de dos semanas
está previsto que el gobierno realice
otra requisiciones en los próximos días
el impacto este conflicto social se ha
alargado y somos conscientes de ello Es
algo insoportable para demasiado
franceses
algunos de los cuales se les impide ir a
trabajar llevar a sus hijos al colegio
mientras las filas en las gasolineras se
alargan en toda Francia en algunos
departamentos los prefectos dan
prioridad a los vehículos de emergencia
y a los cuidadores una medida que no a
todo el mundo le gusta esta es la
tercera estación de servicio en la que
he estado Así que hemos estado luchando
desde esta mañana desde las 7 de la
mañana estoy en la calle ante la
probabilidad de que continúe la escasez
cada vez más sindicatos de las llamadas
profesiones esenciales exigen un acceso
prioritario
cambiamos ahora de tema el 12 de octubre
de 1492 Cristóbal Colón llegó a América
una llegada que desencadenó en la
colonización española del continente
americano más de 500 años después la
fecha sigue causando controversia por
Cómo debe ser nombrada y por si
directamente debe o no ser conmemorada
para analizar el tema Contamos con
Valentina Mena Castro historiadora de la
Universidad javeriana de Colombia
Valentina buenas tardes Cómo cree que
debería conmemorarse este día si cree
que directamente debería estar fijado
como festivo en el calendario
bueno como tal festivo significa que
habría una festividad Y en este caso no
sería una festividad porque
históricamente pues este día nació en
1913 cuando el exministro español
Faustino Rodríguez San Pedro decidió en
la como presidente de la unión
iberoamericana crear esta idea del día
de Colón para unir España y América cuál
es el problema al problema es que si tú
lo llamas como celebración entonces hay
que celebrar que Colón llegó a América
eso desencadenó una serie de matanzas de
enfermedades y de cuestiones que hoy en
día están revaluadas entonces
celebración como tal No pero sí es una
conmemoración de que ocurrió este hecho
de la colonización y que varios pueblos
indígenas también la esclavitud se
originó a raíz de esto y precisamente
las voces que van en la dirección que
usted comentaba en a recordar la
colonización pero no celebrarlo han
cogido fuerza en los últimos años o
simplemente se les ha prestado más Como
por ejemplo recordemos que en Estados
Unidos el presidente Joe biden el año
pasado decretó que ahí el 10 de octubre
cuando tiene lugar la celebración del
Día de Colón en Estados Unidos sería
también el día de los pueblos
originarios A qué se debe digamos Este
cambio en el discurso
bueno el cambio en el discurso se debe
básicamente a las actitudes de la
academia de escuchar otras diferentes
perspectivas no solamente de la historia
con mayúscula de pensarse como que
Colombia vino colonizó hizo todo acá lo
que ocurrió también en Estados Unidos
con la cuestión británica sino que
además Esto ocurrió de manera simultánea
o sea también las personas que eran
parte de estos territorios existían no
fueron descubiertas ellos ya vivían aquí
y es darle voz a estas personas darle su
participación en la historia y
precisamente no hablaba de esta
nomenclatura entre descubrimiento
llegada colonización Cómo se ahora los
estudiantes de América Latina sobre la
llegada de Colón ha cambiado en los
últimos años debería cambiar Claro que
sí pues se tienen dos partes la
contraposición que tenemos desde España
en donde se está hablando de el
Descubrimiento y todas estas miradas
reivindicativas que no solamente es el
descubrimiento sino que también es la
visión de los vencidos que diferentes
autores como gorman tratan y es decir no
solamente es que se descubrió sino que
aquí había personas que estaban viviendo
y que fueron interrumpidas en su vida
porque llegaron otras personas de otras
partes a decir que las descubrieron y se
impusieron y terminaron trayendo
enfermedades muerte y pues diferentes
cuestiones sociales Pues que ya sabemos
que ocurrió
Valentina Mena Muchísimas gracias por su
tiempo y por su análisis Claro que sí
continuamos con otras noticias en Perú
El Congreso estudia la demanda
constitucional interpuesta por la
fiscalía en contra del presidente Pedro
Castillo la fiscal general Patricia
Benavides aseguró que el presidente
dirige una organización criminal lo que
el mandatario catálogo como una nueva
modalidad de golpe de estado este tipo
de denuncia constitucional es un
procedimiento especial que se aplica
exclusivamente a altos funcionarios y se
podría llevar a la destitución si el
congreso lo aprueba
y vamos ahora a Venezuela donde los
trabajadores de rescate aseguraron que
no esperan encontrar sobrevivientes tras
el deslizamiento de tierra ocurrido el
sábado en tejerías en el centro Norte
del país que mató alrededor de 40
personas y dejó 50 desaparecidos
tras días de trabajo incansable Los
rescatistas no tienen más esperanzas
encontrar sobrevivientes pero debajo del
barro y las ramas ven el cuerpo de una
víctima
cinco días después el derrumbe se han
encontrado más de 40 cuerpos pero mucha
gente sigue desaparecida para sus seres
queridos la espera es insoportable
familiares cercanos míos míos y dos
familiares primos lejanos sabes cinco
personas que están desaparecidas Y
todavía ni siquiera aparecían en lista
Quiero comida yo creo que aparezca a mis
familiares de verdad el domingo se
decretó luto nacional por parte de las
autoridades luego de hacerse presente
allí el lunes el mandatario venezolano
Nicolás Maduro dio una nueva valoración
en la televisión Estatal y todavía hay
un número importante desaparecido
56 desaparecidos
estamos llegando casi a un centenar de
víctimas fatales de
esta tragedia este desastre natural el
deslave se produjo el sábado Luego de
lluvias torrenciales en esta región del
centro Norte del país es el peor
desastre natural en Venezuela desde
principios del siglo una catástrofe
relacionada según los expertos al cambio
climático pero agravada por una
Urbanización descontrolada con viviendas
construidas en zonas de riesgo las
autoridades han habilitado alojamientos
de emergencia y han anunciado la
distribución de 300 toneladas de
alimentos
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros en Francia 24 y 24.com
[Música]